Lo que quiero hacer en este video es tratar
de averiguar a qué equivale 35 + 22 + 10 + 16,
así que pausa este video y trata de resolverlo.
Muy bien, ahora trabajemos juntos. Aprenderás
que hay muchas formas de resolver esto, pero la
forma en que me gusta hacerlo es fijándome en
el valor posicional. Por ejemplo, cuando vemos
el 35 tenemos tres decenas y cinco unidades,
tres decenas justo aquí, es lo mismo que 30,
así que puedes ver a 35 como 30 + 5; y podemos
hacer lo mismo para el 22: 22 es dos decenas,
que es 20, esto es lo que nos indica este 2,
más dos unidades, entonces 20 + 2; y luego tenemos
10, que es sólo una decena y ninguna unidad,
entonces más 10; y luego 16, podríamos reescribir
esto como una decena: 10 + 6 unidades. Ahora,
¿para qué nos sirve esto? Pues ahora puedo
tomar todas las cantidades que tienen un cierto
número de decenas como 30, 20, 10 y 10, y trato de
sumarlas, y luego, por separado, voy a sumar el 5,
el 2 y el 6, y cuando veas cómo lo hago te darás
cuenta de por qué es útil hacer esto. Entonces
tenemos 30 + 20 + 10 más este 10 púrpura, así que
ya he contado el 30, el 20, ese 10 y ese 10;
y luego tendré todas las cosas que estaban en la
posición de las unidades, entonces más cinco unidades
-ya conté este-, más dos unidades -ya conté este-,
más seis unidades. Y ahora podemos pensar en todo
esto: ¿qué es 30 + 20? Bueno, 30 + 20 serán 50,
y luego 50 + 10 es 60, y luego 60 + 10 es 70,
así que esto será 70. Otra forma de pensar en
esto es que tenemos tres decenas, más dos decenas,
más una decena, más una decena: 3 + 2 + 1 + 1 es
7, entonces tenemos siete decenas. Y en realidad
también viste eso aquí arriba: tres decenas, más
dos decenas, más una decena, más una decena, eso
nos dará siete decenas. Y luego podemos sumar esta
otra parte, donde vemos que 5 + 2 es 7 + 6 es 13,
entonces es 70 + 13. Ahora, ¿qué es 70 + 13?
Bueno, podría reescribir 13, podría hacer algo
similar a 10 + 3, y eso lo hace un poco más obvio,
podemos ver que es lo mismo que 70 + 10, que es
80 + 3, que es lo mismo que ocho decenas y tres
unidades, que es igual a 83. Y hemos terminado.